Hello and welcome to fire of
learning Niccolo Machiavelli's book.
The prince was published in 1530 to five
years after his death and in this video
we're going to take a look at 10 very
noteworthy tips from that book. As usual,
I will attempt to deliver these
points without personal bias.
The book was written as a sort
of advice guide for politicians,
specifically kings of the time.
Obviously this means taking literally,
it isn't widely applicable as most of
us aren't kings. Maybe you are, I don't,
I don't know.
But the advice is not applicable only
for monarchs or even general politicians.
It can be translated and utilized for
a number of professions and situations
from business to social life to whatever.
So with that in mind, let's get started.
Number 10 distrust,
mercenaries and auxiliaries.
Machiavelli believed that having soldiers
who weren't loyal are dependent on you
was a disastrous error.
These types of soldiers were
only interested in their
own gain or had loyalties
to someone else.
Accordingly,
Machiavelli personally watched as the
Italian states who use these types of
soldiers consistently failed and strongly
suggests raising troops of your own
with a mutual goal. For example, the
success of your kingdom. Number nine,
you can't imitate great people exactly,
but you should try as much as possible.
Essentially,
Machiavelli believed in learning from
those who were successful in history.
In fact,
much of his advice is justified with
examples all the way back to ancient
civilizations within a given position.
According to Machiavelli,
you should attempt to imitate the habits
of those who were successful. However,
of course,
at times it will unavoidably have to
think and act on your own and these
circumstances. Machiavelli advises that
his best to not be reckless. Number eight,
don't increase the power of rivals.
This seems obvious,
but it's mistake far too often mate
Machiavelli used the then recent failed
invasion of Italy by the King of France
as a consistent example throughout the
book. Instead of assisting smaller states
against the larger Italian nations,
he allied himself with the pope
and picked on smaller nations.
The pope took control of this
and seize more power for himself.
Establishing his state as a
dominant in the region. Further,
the King of France made it even worse
by allowing another rival and to the
region. When Spain conquered
Naples in Sicily, number seven,
when conquering new people
don't change too much.
While it's certainly true
that according to Margaret,
one should take measures to ensure the
loyalty of nearly obtained subjects.
He claims that the best way to do this
is to keep their laws taxes and such
things mostly unchanged
and less necessary.
He even recommends allowing
them to forming local
government for their interests.
As long as the government is not hostile,
but dependent on you. Number six,
without power, opportunity is wasted.
Without opportunity. Power is wasted.
Machiavelli believe leadership was a
combination of power and opportunity and
not a wise leader could find ways to both.
Furthermore,
he warns against obtaining
either with fortune,
reminding us that he who depends on
fortunate alone is a ruined when fortune
changes depends upon yourself.
Number five,
we live so far removed from how we ought
to live that he who abandons what is
done for what ought to be done,
we'll destroy himself rather than prevail.
Machiavelli believed that
morality, goodness, and
kindness, we're all nice ideas.
Realistically, one must do what they
have to do to survive, succeed and grow.
He cautions against trying to reform the
system and encourages rather rising and
succeeding in it as change can often be
dangerous, especially if it is forced.
If you must change something though,
do it with strength as armed
profits conquer but unarmed
ones fail. Number four,
support from nobles and support from
the people are two different areas in
either group could ruin you. The nobility
looks to achieve their own interests,
namely by suppressing the people.
The people in turn are interested,
namely and not being suppressed and
ability may threaten you to achieve their
own interest and the people will often
revolt if there are two headily pressed
by you,
in which case the people are usually a
better ally to have for if you're hated
by the people and the ability
will easily remove you.
But if you were loved by the people,
the nobility will have a greater
difficulty dethroning you. Number three,
one must master the art of
acting in the most efficient way,
but looking as good of
a person as possible.
Machiavelli says that a prince should
attempt to look like someone who is
merciful, faithful, respectable,
humane, religious and generous,
but behind the curtain may have to act
in the exact opposite way to achieve
results as a times. Adherence to these
values may not only be disastrous,
but it may come off as weakness and
Machiavelli Warren's greatly against the
ruler who looks timid, frivolous, a
feminine, changeable or a resolute.
The Art of politics, therefore, in his
opinion, is mastering both the worlds.
Number two, it is better to be feared
than to be loved, but if possible,
go for both.
Machiavelli recognizes the importance
of being favored by his subjects,
but knows that too much
leniency may invite trouble.
Lean and sea bass out of love for the
people may suggest a weakness that may
provide opportunities for rivals and
may decrease your power and therefore an
element of fear is necessary in your
ruling in treating others fails.
Using strength and force nearly
always succeeds. And accordingly,
if you have to choose between
being loved and feared,
it is better to go with being feared.
And the number one point from the prince
is at the end justifies the means.
Machiavelli believed that to
achieve efficient results,
princess sometimes have to play a little
bit dirty, playing dirty. In fact,
playing very dirty is
justifiable in his opinion,
as long as the end result is
something favorable and good. However,
he adds onto this that if you're
going to commit an atrocity,
it's better to do it all in
one day than to prolong it.
I he would be better to execute a hundred
people in one day than to kill one
person each day over a hundred days while
each perhaps warrants the same results.
Technically,
the former secures your position with
fear and reassures rivals that you will
act when crossed the ladder,
gives the impression that you rule over
people to radically in that further on
security to people must oppose it to you.
So these have been Machiavelli's top
10 tips from his very famous book,
the Prince.
It's certainly not as only advice though.
I would highly recommend reading the
book and for more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
I would invite you to check out
fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.